Артемівський суд донецької області України
витрачають і річкові владислав савченко чекаючи
на рішення щось своєї долі у
діяльності сама прогулів шо але я днр узо
генц і протестував рен ступив владну
волі
яка особа пішла і міліція прийшла нікому
було нагорода то за порядком прати весь
кулаки у так званої один ервін кров'ю
близько ти женя золотом, а там руках
патрулі вал місця і заповнюєш сюди
тяжкою поліпшенню приємними бу
владислав сам здався п'ять років ланки не
оптимістка українськими скронями та соплі
ганської профі тут ліфтом прокурор
просить суд про бачати до зайвого со
протесту самого вночі савченко так
правильно тому право хоромам у gorga
ну
праві винну досягти ідеальності
добровільно вирішив знає я розкрити
викладених члени їж і учасник які
стич на організацію донецька народної
республіки
суд закрив кримінальну право проти
ладислава розвинули у його гілках праві
дальності
зал та пиріг український судив
хвалила і приблизно 10 судових рішень
цілі давайте у наших програм і
над його чекаєте вдома розрубано збу
полковник збу і гірку людей
куратор програми у донецької області та про
група вже за б запитала амністію впав
на бенкет сотника зайвих ополченців штабу
війська 200 проходять перевірку якщо
людина не брав участь вбивство спроба я
хочу люди на набрала долі вбивствах
туртурро з гвалт увальня хп пограбувань
люди каятися проходити управах рівні
органи і права права втраті
вона може повернутися його органами з його
сам ряду вони
товсту процеси засобом ці 5
розряду ти харчування пит кріслі у розряду
ти про пом'якше не поки поранять звивині
об'їдають за і дальністю відповідальністю
владислав савченко кілька місяців у пари
кого всі види української влади так у
лиж них товариші по так дзвони днр
windows то його невір, що може бути
звивин їм адже кримінальної при
дальності
нібито не програмою сбу юм загороджувала
адже 3 до 8
руки ви знаєте